A pesar de nuestro mejores esfuerzos,
solo reciclamos el 9 % de todo el plástico que usamos.
Y lo que es peor todavía
es que el plástico es súper resistente y duradero
y los investigadores estiman
que puede tardar entre 500 y 5000 años
en descomponerse por completo.
Lixivia contaminantes químicos dañinos en los océanos, en los suelos,
en la comida, en el agua y a nosotros mismos.
¿Cómo terminamos con tantos residuos plásticos?
Bueno, es muy sencillo.
El plástico es barato, duradero, adaptable y está en todas partes.
Pero la buena noticia
es que hay algo más que es barato, duradero, adaptable
y está en todas partes.
Mi investigación muestra que incluso podría ayudarnos
con el problema de la contaminación por plásticos.
Les hablo de las bacterias.
Las bacterias son seres vivos microscópicos invisibles a simple vista
que se encuentran en todas partes,
en todo tipo de entornos diversos y extremos,
desde el intestino humano, la tierra y la piel,
hasta respiraderos en el fondo del océano, que llegan a temperaturas de 400 °C.
Las bacterias viven en todas partes,
en todo tipo de entornos diversos y extremos.
Por lo tanto, tienen que ser muy creativas con sus fuentes de alimentos.
Existen muchísimas de ellas.
Los investigadores estiman que en el planeta existen
5 millones de billones de billones, o sea, un 5 seguido de 30 ceros,
de bacterias en el planeta.
Dado que los seres humanos
producimos 300 millones de toneladas de plástico nuevo por año,
yo diría que la cantidad de plástico
es bastante semejante a la de bacterias.
Y al haber observado esto
y haber aprendido lo creativas que son las bacterias
para encontrar comida,
me puse a pensar:
¿Podrían haber aprendido las bacterias a usar el plástico de comida.
en entornos contaminados por el plástico?
Me propuse investigar esto hace unos años.
Afortunadamente para mí,
vengo de una de las ciudades más contaminadas de EE. UU.:
Houston, Texas.
(Ríe)
Tan solo en mi ciudad
la Agencia de Protección Ambiental (EPA) identificó a siete sitios Superfund.
Estos son sitios tan contaminados,
que el gobierno considera su limpieza una prioridad nacional.
Decidí visitar estos sitios
para recoger muestras de suelo colmado de bacterias.
Empecé a pensar en un protocolo,
que es una forma científica sofisticada de llamar a una receta.
Lo que traté de preparar era un medio sin carbono,
o sea, un entorno sin comida.
Un entorno sin el carbono o comida típicos
que las bacterias necesitan, como los seres humanos, para sobrevivir.
En este entorno
proporcioné a mis bacterias una sola fuente de carbono, o de comida.
Las alimenté con tereftalato de polietileno,
o sea, de plástico PET.
El PET es el plástico más usado en la fabricación de plásticos en el mundo.
Se usa para todo tipo de envases para alimentos y bebidas,
especialmente para las botellas de agua plásticas,
que los seres humanos usamos a razón de un millón por minuto.
Lo que hice
fue poner a las bacterias a dieta forzada de plástico PET
para observar cuáles, si fuera el caso, sobrevivían o prosperaban.
Este tipo de experimento se realizó
para ver si las bacterias se adaptarían a su entorno contaminado por plásticos
y desarrollarían la increíble y genial capacidad de comer plástico PET.
Con este experimento
encontré bacterias que lo hicieron.
Estas bacterias encontraron la manera de comer plástico PET.
Y, ¿cómo lo hacen?
Bueno, en realidad es muy sencillo.
Así como los humanos digerimos el carbono o los alimentos en azúcares
para usarlos como fuente de energía,
estas bacterias hacen lo mismo.
Estas bacterias descubrieron
cómo digerir el resistente y duradero plástico PET.
Para esto emplean una versión especial
de enzimas.
Las enzimas son compuestos que existen en todos los organismos vivientes.
Hay distintos tipos de enzimas,
que hacen funcionar los procesos,
tales como la digestión de alimentos para convertirlos en energía.
Por ejemplo, los seres humanos tenemos una enzima llamada 'amilasa',
que nos ayuda a digerir almidones complejos como el pan,
en azúcares más pequeños, que usamos como energía.
Estas bacterias tienen una enzima especial llamada 'lipasa',
que se une al resistente y duradero plástico PET
y ayuda a descomponerlo en porciones de azúcares
que las bacterias usan para obtener energía.
En resumen,
los plásticos PET pasan de contaminantes enormes, resistentes y duraderos
a una sabrosa comida para las bacterias.
Suena fenomenal, ¿verdad?
Yo creo que dada la envergadura del problema de contaminación por plásticos,
esto parece ser muy útil.
Las estadísticas que les mostré
sobre la cantidad de residuos de plásticos acumulados en el planeta
son abrumadoras.
Dan miedo.
Creo que demuestran
que si bien es importante reducir, reutilizar y reciclar,
estas acciones solas no bastan para resolver el problema.
Y es aquí donde pienso que las bacterias nos pueden ayudar.
Aunque sé que a algunos les preocupará
la idea de la ayuda bacteriana.
Después de todo, si hay plástico en todos lados, y estas bacterias lo comen,
¿no hay un riesgo de que estas bacterias entren al medio ambiente
y causen un desastre?
La respuesta en breve es que no, y lo explicaré.
Estas bacterias ya están en el medio ambiente.
Las bacterias de mi proyecto no son monstruos modificados genéticamente.
Estas son bacterias naturales
que se adaptaron a un entorno contaminado por el plástico
y desarrollaron la increíblemente compleja capacidad de comer plástico PET.
El proceso de que las bacterias coman plástico es realmente natural.
Pero es un proceso increíblemente lento.
Y hay mucho por hacer
para averiguar cómo acelerar el proceso a un ritmo útil.
En mi investigación busco cómo hacerlo
mediante una serie de pretratamientos de UV o ultravioleta,
o sea, básicamente, a bombardear los plásticos PET con luz solar.
Esto se hace porque la luz solar actúa como una enternecedora de carne
y hace que los enlaces de los enormes, resistentes y duraderos plásticos PET
sean un poco más blandos y fácil de masticar para las bacterias.
Por último, mi investigación busca crear
un sistema sin carbono, a escala industrial,
como en el abono,
para que las bacterias puedan prosperar en un sistema cerrado,
donde su única fuente de alimento son residuos de plástico PET.
Imaginen que algún día podrán deshacerse de sus residuos de plástico
en un contenedor en la calle
sabiendo que va a una planta de residuos plásticos alimentada por bacterias.
Creo que lo podemos convertir en realidad.
Las bacterias que comen plástico no son una cura para todo.
Pero dadas las estadísticas actuales, está claro que los seres humanos,
necesitamos un poco de ayuda en esto.
Porque, gente,
tenemos un imperioso problema con la contaminación por plásticos.
Y la ayuda de las bacterias quizá forme una parte importante de la solución.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)